welcome to this video playing Grand
Master orange from israel now Lady Govs
Dean quite a good GM and blitz player he
improved a lot in online blitz in recent
times I have played him my years ago and
strangely enough with age she got better
check his inner 60s I think John late
50s so really strong blitz player ok
I've had I've tried this semi tirage
again without really knowing what i'm
doing i hope it works out just trying to
play normal developing news yeah ok this
cannot be bad again the smooth maybe I
shouldn't do that it was a problem in
this earlier game who I tried this
opening maybe this is in fact
interesting ok well he's the higher
rated going let's let him come up with
something he probably won't just draw
hm
Queen g6 is a draw right isn't it I die
but today we won't claim he won't claim
it and I don't want to draw I just
wanted to to provoke something mmm yeah
Knight f6 i can draw with Queen f6 now
but ok this is not this is no fun let's
let's play on the should be one my queen
the draw was objectively speaking much
better this is this is clear I hope I've
no place for the Queen besides h6 and
this is not really great ok maybe it's
not as terrible as it looks because the
bishop is really misplaced on d1 and I
have some play with rook d8 I mean
nothing I didn't plan any of that but
maybe this is still valid yeah this is
quite ok Union rock c3 c3 em look C 3 2
a 3 we can take onee phone because of
the back rank he really just weakened
the back rank
to have an enormous bishop now 25 okay
well it's a very nice position check
look III and taking adam white resides
Jim a bit of an early resign but I get
the a pawn I just get the a porn yeah he
just blundered he 4tube its own a bit a
bit lucky i mean not lucky I wasn't I
wasn't worse I think but of course he
shouldn't he shouldn't lose out right
it's very lucky that I'm not that I'm
not losing here really because I really
overlooked that the queen is in so much
trouble and the fun thing is that this
is actually good for black the computer
likes black here yeah it's because of
this some somewhat weird piece
configuration these are not working well
and they have a look already on the C
file and I've worked yet while this
weekend pawn structure is not not an
immediate problem he cannot attack those
pawns and yeah this is some quite okay i
mean the compare is on minus 0.2 so like
about equal and once the play age three
yeah this just blunders the game away
and i think due to the two to the back
rank
yeah and this is rather easy because
it's also this phenomenal bishop on d5
it cannot easily be expelled from d5 and
I have this a pawn to attack plus two
against one so it's not super difficult
technically an early resigned
nevertheless okay nice win but of course
he helped a lot en thanks for watching